what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to continue a
show that we are very much enjoyed it's
called Reacher season one episode
threats here's we're gonna ask you to do
if you end up enjoying our reaction or
if you just want to be kind up front
leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated also subscribe and click the
notification Bell get notified when our
next reaction for Reacher is up here on
the Chanel as always full-length
Reaction watch along is where you sync
up with your own copy is available
exclusively for our super sexy rejects
over at our patreon page massive thank
you to all who have joined just for this
show alone but we also cover several
things over there exclusively with the
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included John you ready to continue this
show so ready I'm so excited let's get
it going people
I know you're scared but I'm scared you
know I was recruited
by the F diligence
scored a 99th percentile in IQ but only
an 80 on the Sika value wanna know why
Yukon descending [__] welcome
personal skills
the ability to tolerate horse [__] they
came into my house that I fixed up with
my money in the town that my family
founded because they think they are
Untouchable what
she is so good you want a gun
[Laughter]
so good Roscoe for the win man great
gave this to me a couple years ago
I wanted to keep it in the family and I
was the only family he had the gun is
that a desert eagle John knows he goes
shooting off use it wrong if it gets
back to me
there's some trust I won't let anything
happen to it you put your life before
this gun protected as though it were my
child God Dion the body that was found
with Joe
we gotta get to the morgue
action scene action scene explosion
never trust a weapon you haven't
personally test fire
cops will be there momentarily now you
took him out drinking good thing I did
whoever killed the Morrisons came after
us last night broke into my house carved
a threatened in my door who knows what
they would have done if I've been there
alone
but did you have sex
victim's name is Pete Joplin trucker oh
looks fancy not the kind of from the
defense truck drivers hopefully we don't
need to see you again anytime soon no oh
no just for every episode not duel
Jasper uh hi Molly Beth ah ciao
oh thank God why haven't you returned my
calls I was worried pretend oh boy Miss
Gordon this is Jack Reacher Joe's dead
no you're wrong
I'm not oh
she loved him do you know what Joe was
doing in margrave Georgia
he was running a classified
investigation I just don't know the
details no they were personally involved
I can try to get his files for you hard
copies only we don't want anything
leading back to you we need to keep this
quiet shouldn't I tell his superiors
absolutely not
you sound just like him
they don't look alike teal doesn't know
we suspect him so we play this game for
now I tell him you found your house
broken into and you're determined to
find out who's responsible I'm going to
pay a visit to that jail guard Spivey
this Spivey guy such a weasel no you're
gonna go see Zacharias Perez LLP see
what you can find on Bob Joplin's arrest
an assignment oh someone came after you
appears that way it could be related to
Morrison could be teen for the dub sense
of humor yeah
um I know some about that what about
Finley I think you might know something
here in Sharon I doubt it Stevenson
a moment I've had your entire family
incarcerated something tells me Finley's
gonna die this season
Mr Spivey
wadding in here
creepy old woman it's a log lady from
Twin Peaks
Mr Spivey
cool they got that in one shot
your boy skipped town or is just about
to come back
that's topical
I was gonna make that joke I didn't
think they'd actually go there truth be
told Mr Doyle
I'm sorry what was your first name again
Brian
Doyle I made up a story so you'd see me
now give me your file on Pete Goblin
yeah
boss for a traffic violation and
disorderly conduct charge who the hell
do you think you are a pissed off
Drifter with nothing to lose and he has
a gun I will ruin your life with one
phone call I'll end your life with one
phone
bars
no dude pull up traveling's file
be careful just print it
oh
oh my god listen man you should have
told us you were a cop
this defense again this is a small town
yep and it shouldn't make a difference
whoa whoa whoa now you don't need to
preach at me whoa creature which one you
[__] did this thought he was a
burglar
how many burglars you know wear suits
you didn't look like you lived there are
you kidding me right now hey whoa Roscoe
take him down I love you Roscoe you know
cursing is a sign of a weak mind and a
week of character what the [__] you
talking about man comedium at jolene's
said he found something
Jolene Jolene Jolene
love the Southern Gothic Vibe it's
Gothic the right word got everything I
needed
how
just
use the phone you strangle him with a
phone wire it's the kind of things you
gotta think about Butternut chicken
sandwich with coleslaw and for you
spinach salad dressing on the side I
want to eat those embarrass ordering
that how do you eat like that and still
look like you do thank you for asking I
had the exact same question which is
like you never see this guy work out
life is a workout when a trucker got
into legal trouble
legal fees but I'm gonna break into
kleiners tonight and see if I can find
something that connects in you can't
just sit there and say you're going to
violate the Fourth Amendment while you
eat okra
if you jeopardize this investigation if
you get evidence that's inadmissible
because it was unlawfully obtained
you get that busted nose filling out a
warrant to search spivey's house sure I
was wondering about that exigent
circumstances are exceptions to the
warrant requirements
that's [__] but it's legal
Rigs and murtuck I'll walk in and talk
to him man that powerful someone's got
to keep a cool head
I'm taking those ribs to go
oh my God I hope he gets to keep this
dog by the end of the show jackwick
[Music]
I shoot this in Canada
there's like a Canada show I'm not a
single security camera
right this way Mr clanner is expecting
you
roll out the Welcome Wagon it was a hell
of a lot of animal feedback there
oh this is South they all have got cows
and a secret weapon I'll do the talking
good wow I don't like talking
family of skilled marksmen
good clue perhaps Mr Spivey has a buddy
on the loading dogs
where they're just making plans to grab
a beer after work or perhaps he was
calling for another reason to get a dead
beer after work you're only doing your
job and I know you're just trying to get
answers about your brother's death
but if I may speak frankly I am getting
defensive
I'm a little insulted to be under
suspicion more than a little my
intention was never to insult you Mr
Kleiner
follow the clues man you've had some
trouble settling in here Captain I
wonder why that is way to flip it maybe
it's because you're a northerner fancy
education
[Music]
this evidence Trail you're following
but it's a waste of time for you
and for me
God
leave it I like the performance
never say you're threatening but be
threatening the whole time my father's
name
Horatio Finley you might think you're
everybody's daddy in this town
which is not mine nice
if you keep talking to the cops on my
Force
enter this investigation in any way
hit him I will put my [__] foot up
your [__] ass until your heart stops
yes you will he swore three times till
my heel comes out your mouth I mean he's
at a rough 24 hours you know
look at these guys they look like demons
from Supernatural they do
if it is Canada that would explain a lot
of cursing is a sign of weak mind and
weaker character he wasn't there for the
conversation with her how do you know
that
I'm my daddy
kleiner's a bully
bullies need to know they can be
punished too flashback
don't cry no matter what
young Joe and young Reacher I mean Jack
we just came from the hospital
I heard his Bishop had his face bashed
in with this holy [__]
there were bicycle tracks leaving
Curtis's house right there
to your bike Joe
you got to learn cover up man dude Joe
did you do this
step up Jack
blame
all signs indicate yes
Kleiner knows you suspect him we don't
know who to trust at the station
motels cash fake names travel light you
may live like you
like a hobo plus you get to come up with
so many fun Back stories for yourself
let's hear the word for hobo Viagra uh
he was getting a ton of food delivered
today it's not like he's running a
commercial Farm
it's Georgia a lot of folks have cows
that's what I hear
we're not dealing with the small scale
operation this thing's a Hydra I cut off
one head two more grow in this place
there's no justice for Joe and that woof
I'm gonna uncover this whole operation
then Burn It to the Ground
now it takes time which is something I
have in great quantity you got this
Odysseus inspire me the answer I get him
to rat on whoever paid him to kill
Hubble we know everything and neither
you were coming with me
we made instantly you both yeah and you
look like a personal trainer
even with that Reacher guy a lot lately
your mama teach you the way to a girl's
heart is stalking her I wouldn't have to
resort to this if you would ever go out
with me
Flawless logic you guys are so close you
must have told you about Baghdad right
about those civilians that he killed if
you don't let me into my truck right now
I'm gonna have you face down on the hood
handcuffs
like that
I don't think he ultimately would I'm
looking out for your Roscoe I care about
you these are caring eyes
this is caring intimidation that looks
like Colin jost's brother yeah he's mad
that he didn't get SNL
there she is
Nice Shot damn right I'm busting up more
clay in a Tuscan earthquake
Debbie Shane you're from Charleston
mm-hmm how's that son of a gun Tom Sloan
doing still a son of a gun in every way
possible
what division are you in account
services but truth be told I started out
wanting to work in currency management
we had a guy handling that for us but he
picked up and left about a year ago and
we discontinued the department
I'm confused you're a currency manager
what did you say his name was again but
it was Paul Hubble up and left without
someone just two weeks notice kind of a
move if you ask me
fascinating
ring falls on the ground except for
grass
really says who the law
famous case of finders versus Keepers
never heard of it
I was just being told about this
This legal terminology for real I'm on a
Case uh can't seem to untangle what you
got to say
get the hell on Dodge
why are you staying it's my damn job
because we're the only ones who want to
make things right
seems like a good reason this woman
seems like she's not real and he's
opening up a lot so why don't we find
another bar around here
of the pool tables and cheaper drinks
she is a hit man maybe even a dark
corner somewhere and see where the
Knight takes us dude make it happen I'm
flattered
then you're nice too
when I'm not your guy okay
oh it's a Hubble was secretly working
for them I guess so off the books for a
whole last year you know Tanner Spivey
spot is a friend and you don't need
anyone asking about his business
find himself another bar
two yeah boxer
Southpaw Golden Gloves I know the thing
about boxing
too many rules
oh yes sir
1-1 you left down it was some Spanish
guys man real fast Golden Gloves there
not subtle tail guy
he's gonna go back in and take
everyone's phone
great tracking shot
[Laughter]
ah great shot
he's still got the tape on his jacket
too it's good
sack like you belong there
foreign
there you go stay close
not too close slam the brakes
smart
perfect what timing oh we're gonna see a
reach her with a gun
please say que pasa before you shoot
them
let's get some Noir Lighting in here
perfect shots
collect your brass
sweet he has money is that real money
hello Spivey
damn
oh [__]
I hope Hubble's still alive yeah he'll
come back as the villain all right take
it away John ah that was ah just a
little absolute I can't like every time
one of these stops I just want to binge
which doesn't happen to me a lot of
shows usually I'm like yeah I'm content
to like sit with this and wait but this
is uh yeah it's just been so engrossing
and I like that in this episode among
all the other lovely things that have
remained consistent we got a little bit
of intimacy or at least a little window
into the life of Finley
thought his little meat cute situation
was nice it was nice to watch him go off
on his own and do some investigating and
you know not go on full Jack Reacher
mode but you know at least watch him do
some undercover work and things like
that even though you know he basically
just made up a name in a position but uh
yeah just the mystery and the the
mounting tension is uh is is just really
nice and permeating and I think that
they've done a great job thus far of
yeah building this tapestry of
bunch of suspicious characters and I I
don't know like I feel like the answer
hasn't quite revealed itself yet or like
the person who you know might be truly
at the head of this Hydra you know
probably hasn't been revealed yet but
either way like you know just the web of
Suspicion I find quite intriguing and uh
and yeah the style the attitude
everything just remains Top Notch yeah I
think what this show does really well is
while they keep the mystery really
prevalent and keeps you on the journey
with them uh they they really put a lot
of attention into how the investigation
affects our characters on this journey
which is the thing that keeps you
emotionally engaged you know like
watching what Finley goes through here
uh don't know the actor's name probably
won't learn until the end of the show
but watching what he goes through he
this performance requires such a level
of restraint that I think he exercises
quite well because when he goes through
the things she goes through and hear you
know with getting
um assaulted and then thrown in jail for
being black
he still manages to contain everything
and even you know has that line to
Roscoe about swearing and showing
weak-minded character and stuff like he
just has to really stay resilient in the
path and not allow himself to break but
then you see some of those Shades break
through it's like this relationship they
form with him and reach her you know
that as much as Finley loves to play by
the code and play by the book there's
this other side to Finley that is like
Reacher that is just waiting to come out
you know it's like and and this tug and
pull and Reacher I think the performance
I do with I know his name and everyone's
mentioned it to me Alan Richardson what
they've done with uh Richard and Finley
is like reachers constantly just like
he's got like a
a hook just latched into Finley and he's
just slowly pulling out that other side
of him
and that's what makes the chemistry so
fun with watching those two especially
go back and forth like I even though he
had that beginning part with Roscoe last
episode seem to get you a lot more
Roscoe this one seems to get you a lot
more of it into the the mindset of who
Finley is
um and yeah I think that's what makes
this show that's what makes the show
more engaging than anything else like I
like the action I love the look I love
the southern Flair throughout and I love
the performance by Alan Richardson and
the Mystery is is fun it's a fun mystery
I'm not like I'm never like on the I
haven't found myself like on the edge of
my seat about it I'm still engaged and I
still want to know what's happening and
I'm like I'm keeping up with it going
like oh yeah I mean
yeah I guess that's what I'm waiting for
it's like
what's the
is there someone that we should have
been suspecting but we just never did is
it is it going to be that show like it
doesn't really matter to me honestly if
it is uh because everything else about
the journey is so much fun like going to
recliner Kleiner yeah going to Kleiner
and him being
obnoxiously suspicious sure like dude
doesn't even like
make an effort
right to the to the tandemic
I recommend you drop this and I can make
things really difficult for you and you
don't respect what I've contributed to
this town
yeah uh the that that whole scene you
know like they're cutting through the
[__] there to be like no no I
suspect him suspect him and I don't
think they want you to drop suspected
him and nor do I feel like he's off the
leash I mean I'd be very surprised if
he's not responsible for it he's like
he's off the roads leading to him
um so so there I think they're the least
having fun with their villain now
um but yeah I mean like the the
investigation the mystery is fun and
like I didn't see the twist of Spivey
being dead uh in the trunk there uh but
right now it isn't engaged like they do
a lot with with their characters and to
me that stands out so much like that
makes it really interesting and ways
that are more subtle than you would uh
expect like they're they they're
energetic so they're not like so subtle
like they're not like Breaking Bad stuff
but they're subtle enough but also
expressive enough uh will via dialogue
and through just characters emotions
that yeah it makes they make the journey
fun to see what they go on and
shouts out to the woman at the beginning
too who has a really hard job as an
actress because she's not in the room
with them at all yeah and odds of her
actually playing off that phone call
with Alan Richardson are very slim that
she really had that call so she had to
just work alone in a room with the whole
crew pointed at her and build this whole
history with Joe Reacher and deliver
like what probably just felt like a
[__] monologue when she was filming
it yeah and um and not have like the
real actors to bounce off of and she
really sold that scene very well and you
even watch the uh sympathetic side come
out of Reacher during this phone call
like there is a connection there like
this woman could have been his
sister-in-law in some scenario like you
know uh so I thought I thought they did
a really great job I think they did a
really good job with the characters and
and that the show has a great balance I
think and I think that's why it succeeds
so well it has a great balance of the
fun and energy and equippiness with the
characters and the mystery and nothing
ever seems to tip the line too much well
they seem to have a really good uh
they're very conscientious about I think
when to tell you or to to clearly kind
of cue you to something and then let you
enjoy the the fun of that like him
I think actually there's kind of an
example of both in this moment there are
times where they'll let an action play
out and they won't really let you know
what it is so you're just sort of like
okay what is Jack about to do or what is
you know this situation going to unfold
into and then there are other times
where you know what's about to happen
and they use that to their advantage
without having to like explicitly spell
it out for you so they're good at like
making you wonder and then rewarding you
with certain bits of you know uh you
know catharsis or satisfaction while
still you know keeping the the situation
feel like it's ever growing and I think
too just like watching these three
episodes like every department is on
points like the location even if it is
Canada feels really tangible and all the
casting like even this episode had two
at least you know a few but like two
very prominent like guest actors who you
know were just small roles we might
never see again we might see again but
they leave good Impressions about that
scene at the bar uh the scene on the
phone at the beginning uh you know
character like that and the writing that
you know direction of everything and
they'll do things like have like a oh
cool like you know one take of some kind
but not in like the most in your face
kind of like look at us doing a one take
kind of way like they there's like
really solid work across every
department and I just think they they
it's a great example of just like really
finely tuned
you know Murder Mystery storytelling
yeah they make Jack Reacher surprisingly
believable like he's a larger than life
character I'm sure there's some version
of a guy like this that exists in some
way but he's like six foot nine and he's
like 500 pounds of pure muscle uh he's
built like a God and and he just goes
about his day he's all wandering hobo
you know yeah and and that's even in the
scene in the bar it's like all eyes on
me yeah I'm gonna walk back in here and
go through the kitchen uh you can whoop
anyone's ass he's he's the larger he's
he's a much larger in life character
like he he yet they the show manages to
find the right tone and Rhythm to where
it's very believable and I mean and of
course a lot of credit to his
performances as well the actor Alan Rich
there's a lot of credit goes to that
yeah but there there is a scenario where
this would have been very like this is
so unrealistic you know but they managed
to make it feel believable uh and and
part of what keeps it fun you know
alrighty guys well what did you think
about episode three of Jack Reacher
we're trying to get these up at least
every two to three days
um because uh we know everyone binges
the show instead of don't go into one
week at a time so we're trying to keep
within the Rhythm at least it just it
takes some time to put these together
but uh thank you for being here uh be
sure to leave a like subscribe thank you
again everyone to follow us on our
patreon page but before we go let's end
this with a patreon
yeah
shouts out to Brian Perry Brian we
really don't know a lot about you you're
a mysterious Wanderer amongst our
patreon a Viagra if you will what's it
called a vagrance a vagrant if you will
walking around our patreon and making an
impression getting shouted out and
getting a lot of attention every single
month yet we really have no clue as to
who you are you are the mysterious Lone
Wolf badass at our patreon page and it's
good to have you here sir Brian Perry
appreciate you being here appreciate you
supporting the reject Nation putting the
extra foot forward by giving such a
generous pledge you rock my friend you
keep being sexy and keeping us safe in
the shadows
back